- [Voiceover] Use the
"Rotate" tool to find
the image of pentagon CDEFG, that's this
irregular pentagon over here,
when rotated 270 degrees about the point
negative two comma three.
The direction of rotation
by a positive angle
is counter-clockwise.
So it's counter-clockwise.
All right. Rotate tool, to rotate around
negative two comma three.
So let's click on "Rotate," and then
we want to go to the
point, they said rotate
around the point negative two comma three.
So I move this, to x equals negative two,
y equals three.
That's what we want to rotate around,
and we want to rotate 270 degrees.
So this is maybe the part that takes
the most visualization.
If we rotate 90 degrees, that would be
going from, if we think about this arrow,
actually, let me just do it.
So, if I move this arrow up here,
I have rotated 90 degrees,
positive 90 degrees,
we're moving counter-clockwise.
Now if I move it over
here, we have rotated
180 degrees, and now I move it down here.
I have now rotated it 270 degrees.
If they said 360, we would
get back to where we started.
So this is 270 degrees, just like that.
And, we're done.
Let's check our answer,
if we got it right.